all right Stacy when you lean forward
try not to lean your head out of frame
oh dang it this will be this thing where
your brain has to live hello reject
nation greg alba here so howard Stacy Oh
Howard is here with us today
how are you Stacy I'm ready to watch
some vids with you it's been a while
it's been a while I wanted to be here
today with Stacy because I have a little
announcement to make
john humpty dumpty and i are gonna be
hosting an event at arena sinha lounge
the place Stacy works at she dispenses
the popcorn oh she's a coordinator or
something I do special events marketing
stuff like that they are a fantastic
indie theatre they're on Sunset
Boulevard they show movies seven nights
a week if you guys ever want to come
they take movie paths as well or like 16
bucks a ticket we are gonna do a special
presentation with you guys that are
promoting us that's her job right there
yeah July 7 fans can come and meet you
guys and watch a film clips whatever it
is we're gonna do we have a special
thing in mind it's not just gonna be we
watch a movie it will be very
interactive with the audience and yes we
will talk with everyone before and after
the event too we're not gonna be like
Stacy won't be there and we'll try to
get as many people that come out as
possible for weeks people have been
asking us to check out the house that
built Jack it's a trailer from lars von
trier a fantastic director makes like
family-friendly films I have only seen
nymphomaniac with my mother Volume one
and two only person I like to watch lars
von trier movies with and I found out
you've seen Antichrist melancholia and
nymphomaniac Volume one and two yeah so
you are Lars von Trier
they're really [ __ ] up movies which I
like and I'm a fucked-up kind of gal oh
that bodes well for the male demographic
fine little hosta
are you allowed to speak along the way I
was thinking there might be rules
interesting let me put it this way way
if you make it all the way without
uttering a word but do clearly are
merrily just don't believe you're going
to tell me something I am dirt before
this is a lars von trier movie if you
put she just happens to have a piece of
killer equipment I was maybe in this day
was me getting in this car with you you
might as well be a serial killer sorry
you do kind of look like what okay I've
got to a picture of it yes watching
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus right
[Music]
some people claim that the atrocities we
commit in our fiction are those inner
desires which we cannot commit in our
controlled civilization so they are
expressed instead through our art I
don't agree I didn't have it in hell on
one of the same the soul belongs to
heaven and the body to hell
[Music]
the response here the movie what I think
about all the things I've done in my
life without in any way resulting in
punishment
I know what we're screening on July 7th
people what the hell there's there's
like a post-credits scene in this
trailer I think so the same goes for
murder okay so what did I not get when
they cut to the animals I know Lars von
Trier likes to do his interesting
cutaways you say interesting okay
however he literally is just like oh
here this isn't symbolism this is
exactly what I'm saying this thing is
okay so what was it
okay so Matt Dillon is like the tiger
who was about to pounce on a little lamb
which is uma Thurman like there's no
further thinking's to do
he's just straight-up showing you what I
love about him he's never pretentious
you know is trying not to be anxious I
mean Antichrist I actually turned it off
before it got crazy you missed a chance
I'd be like I heard there's some gross
stuff in here they just felt like coming
I was like I don't know
iver or I regret detailed descriptions
is snippety-snip
on there and I can only imagine that for
a story about an actual serial killer
how violent this one's actually gonna be
it's probably gonna be like nauseating
this feels like it's just self-indulgent
in this guy's life he's even saying in
the trailer and thinking about the
things I've done with no punishments
yeah so we're just gonna watch this guy
have a rockin good time like no conflict
for this guy at all just a series of
events of him brutally murdering people
and trying to up his ante on how he does
it like nymphomaniac don't yawn yeah
that is so unprofessional John Humphrey
2.0 over here no shocking image in there
was probably when he's like dragging the
body down the road yeah was shocked I
thought it was shocking when he just
Thurman in the face with that thing like
they don't hide the fact that no this is
this year
killer that you will see murder and maim
and do a lot of other fucked-up things
do I kind of like mine uma thurman's
like you for all I know you could be a
serial this reminds me of those 70s even
like 80s movies where there's kind of
this grungy type of you know like Henry
portrait of a serial killer or type of
deal yeah just this study of life of
this dude killer yeah it has a 70s vibe
about it it does and it is that the 70s
I guess cuz the clothes and there's
awesome glasses yeah I kind of want
those I feel like they'd be in style if
I worn it like a brunch spot oh dude it
would totally work totally work or
Allison Janney and it's a film about the
serial killer but it's not oh he's the
bad guy in this scenario let's see how
these good guys you know the victims get
out of it it's just about his life we're
supposed to look at and sympathize and
empathize with his side of the story I
guess is that kind of film so fly on the
wall when it's like 70 cinematography
behind it there's a vibe I'm kind of
diggin about it that's the thing about
law response here I'm always very in and
out of his movies I'm invested and then
I'm like oh god this is annoying but
Matt Dillon looks like he's doing a
great job
he's very believable oh yeah for some
awards for this I mean that already for
next year at the least like some of the
Festival Awards I heard that whatever
the big film festival was that had
premiered at that it was what it was one
of those films where everyone just kept
walking out of it like people were so
disturbed by how disgusting it again
that's also a Lars von Trier thing
because dude he like compared himself to
Hitler and say
I understand something I love doing like
banned from every festival
some people love that some people don't
I would love for Matt Dillon to say hi
to that dog next door dog has seen this
movie and he's trying yeah don't watch
it terrible guy it's not we finally got
to watch that trailer I don't know if
I'm gonna watch this his movies scare me
in the sense of like I don't know if I
can endure it I will definitely watch on
Netflix alone in my room but I don't
want people to judge me for being in the
theater watch it for sure out of
curiosity I don't know if this is a
theater kind of movie though I think I
have like 25 minutes left of
nymphomaniac volume 2 and I didn't even
complete that journey I was like you
know I'm not that invested in weird
places I mean I actually enjoyed vol 1
where she's like the young girl and
seeing how someone can develop into
something like that but the second part
I was like you can relate you know well
guys thanks for tuning in to the reject
nation today I'm so glad we could watch
this trailer you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Bell check out Stacey o
Howard on Instagram and Twitter and keep
a look out for the event that she is
helping us put together at arena Cinna
loungin you know sometimes I'm just
there just go check out the theater on
your own yeah
July 7th is gonna be the event but if
you guys want to visit the theater
before then we do indie films older
films classic the Oscar I saw Planet of
the Apes there was last week one for the
Cuckoo's Nest we do a lot of good good
films good films to be had